ERIC BIDELMAN: So
hey, everybody.
Welcome.
Thanks for joining us today.
We're going to talk a little
bit about Polymer, a new
framework that Google is
building based off of Web
Components.
We're really excited about Web
Components on the Chrome team.
We're here in London.
We sort of took a special trip
and wanted to introduce you
guys to a few members
of the team.
My name is Eric.
I work on our Chrome developer
relations team.
And my focus right now as is
Polymer and Web Components.
Do you guys want to introduce
yourself?
MATT MCNULTY: Sure
I'm Matt McNulty.
I lead the engineering team
that works on Polymer.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: And I'm
Alex Komoroske.
I work on Chrome's Open Web
Platform team, but I'm also
really interested in
Polymer stuff.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Cool.
And so Polymer is something we
originally talked about at
I/O. And so we're here today
to answer some of your
questions and obviously start to
have more of these sessions
that we can talk to you guys and
cover the different topics
in Web Components.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: It's definitely
the beginning.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Definitely
There's a lot of stuff coming
out in web platform.
I would say more so than it
ever has in the past.
It's really exciting.
But today let's talk a little
bit about Polymer, give you a
brief, brief introduction,
and then answer
some of your questions.
So what the heck is Polymer?
One of you guys want to start?
What's the goal of Polymer?
What is it?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So Polymer
is a new type of
library for the web.
And the idea is to help use
some of the new, emerging
standards and provide feedback
to them to make sure that they
are useful standards.
That they're going to
be really powerful.
And also help build a community,
an ecosystem around
Web Components, really.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's right.
And we're doing that through
a set of polyfills.
A polyfill library is
essentially polyfilling the
native API before it's
available in a lot of browsers.
And so this is great because you
can use this awesomeness
of Web Components today
in modern browsers.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So one thing
people don't realize,
actually, is speccing out new
web platform features is
really hard to do correctly.
So if you just do it in a closed
room with very smart
people discussing it, if you
don't use it, it's very hard
to see how it's going to
feel in real life.
And so this polyfill approach
actually allows you to use it
and go, oh, feels weird,
and provide
feedback back to the specs.
In fact, we're seeing
a lot with Polymer.
A bunch of people are using
Polymer, providing feedback,
people on the team.
And then we're bringing that
back to the standards bodies.
And using that as examples
of this one felt weird.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Absolutely.
MATT MCNULTY: That's actually
one of the great things about
this team and the entire project
is that we're on the
Chrome team, but we interact
with the standards bodies.
And we come from a web
development background.
Being at that intersection
is really exciting.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: And with Blink
engineers as well.
So we're talking all time with
the guys who were implementing
this within Blink.
ERIC BIDELMAN: And I'm super
happy to see a lot of awesome
developers are coming on
our developer forum.
So we have a Google group, at
polymer-dev googlegroups.com.
And framework authors, right?
People that actually build
frameworks in their own widget
libraries, or whatever.
And they're coming with their
expertise helping us flesh out
some of the stuff as we're
developing Polymer.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Yeah, it's
really exciting to see this,
because you can tell it's the
beginning of what's going to
be really thriving ecosystem,
a bunch of different
frameworks and developers
and standards.
It's really cool.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So it's
a set of polyfills.
That's the foundation.
Maybe it's more showing.
We have an architecture
diagram of--
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I want to
clarify that, though, because
it's not just polyfills.
I think that's something that
a lot of people think.
They see Polymer, polyfills,
it's the same.
It's actually quite a
bit more than that.
And so here on this diagram that
we have on project site,
the red is the polyfills.
The idea is that it allows you
to pretend it creates a stable
foundation that allows you to
pretend like you're living in
the future.
So you can just use
these technologies
as though they existed.
Now, of course, because they're
Polyfills, over time,
as browsers implement those,
you don't need the
polyfills as much.
And so, ultimately, in
theory, that layer
will entirely go away.
ERIC BIDELMAN: There's a lot of
nuance to this chart here.
And that's why this red areas
is sort of staggered, is
because at different points in
time over the next couple of
years the browsers will
have implemented
these different API.
And so, again, these go away.
Which is great.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So a great
example is mutation observers
is actually something that we
have as a polyfill support in
there for browsers that
don't have it.
But most browsers do.
And so that's a great example.
That's why it's a little bit
shorter in this diagram.
Because it's already well
on its long way to being
[INAUDIBLE] deployed.
ERIC BIDELMAN: And so as a
developer, like Alex said, you
can use these different pieces,
sort of a la carte.
You can use just the platform
polyfills if you want.
That's part of Polymer.
But then we add, we go
one layer up, right?
And that's polymer.js.
That's what we call the core,
Colonel, what have you.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: That's where
opinion starts coming in.
The red part is really
just the specs.
It's just the things that
are being standardized.
The yellow is where opinion
starts coming about how you
should be using these
together.
So conveniences, things that
allow you to reduce
boilerplate and to really just
be as productive as possible
on top of this.
But it's a very light opinion.
It's somewhat behind
the scenes.
ERIC BIDELMAN: I think the way
I really see it is Web
Components in general, all these
specs that they see the
red layer here are coming
together, but it's really the
Polymer core that we've
identified as necessary in
order to build a full-fledged
application.
We need to sort of work these
custom APIs together and use
them in a way, things like
MDV, and data binding and
event listeners and what not.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Specifications
are generally designed to not
have much of an opinion.
And so this is where sometimes
you do need a little bit of
opinion to wire it together in
the way that works best for
end web developers.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's right.
And then what's the
green, Alex?
You want to explain the
green a little bit?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So the
green, we've actually
got two boxes there.
Again, this is a very rich
diagram with a lot
of stuff going on.
The first one there is
Polymer elements.
And that's just basically,
they're Web Components that
are built on top of
this the stack.
And they don't necessarily
actually print
anything to the screen.
So these are using one of core
tenants, actually, of Polymer,
one of our parts of opinion, is
this notion of everything
is an element.
And this is the one that we
say it again and again.
And it's a mantra.
At the beginning people
are like, oh I get it.
You probably don't get it.
Think about it harder.
Because it really changed
the way you think.
ERIC BIDELMAN: I didn't
get it at first.
It takes awhile to wrap your
head around this new way to
develop applications.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: When you see,
one of the custom elements
that we've got there now
is in the Polymer Ajax.
ERIC BIDELMAN: I'll bring
up the [INAUDIBLE].
MATT MCNULTY: Polymer is, at
its core, I don't think we
really, completely
introduced it.
We were just talking about
all the nuances of it.
ERIC BIDELMAN: There's a lot
of stuff to introduce.
MATT MCNULTY: A lot of what it
does is it uses all these new
standards to create
custom elements.
And really it's a custom element
building framework.
And you can make custom elements
that are really,
really, really complicated up
into including an entire app,
or just very simple ones.
And one of the great things
about custom elements in these
new standards is you can
sprinkle these things
throughout an existing page or
you can create something new
that is just Polymer.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Absolutely.
And one thing too, is the way
I think of it is these new
technologies of Web Components
are so powerful that people
don't know yet how to
use these right.
And so we're trying to help,
along with the rest of the
ecosystem, discover this.
Be pioneers and try
things out.
See what works, what doesn't.
What things should
be in Element.
What things shouldn't.
Our opinion, so far,
is that everything
should be in Element.
So that's what we got
there at the bottom,
that lower green box.
It's things that are elements
that you can use to do useful
functions, useful [INAUDIBLE].
ERIC BIDELMAN: And just pointing
out, we already have
a base set of what Alex
is describing.
It's things like doing
Ajax, right?
Making an element that actually
just performs Ajax
under the hood.
And then you can do really
interesting things with data
binding to that element.
And it's a totally different
way to think about it, and
we're going to say this again
and again and again, but it's
very, very powerful when you
combine this stuff together,
declaratively.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Everyone has the
moment where they go, oh.
And that's when they get it.
When their eyes go like that.
MATT MCNULTY: Then they'll
understand why we say
everything is in Element.
ERIC BIDELMAN: I mean,
you can imagine.
If all this stuff here that
you're seeing in this page was
built into HTML natively,
right?
Look at this functionality
you could possibly have.
Now we're giving developers
that opportunity to build
whatever they want.
Whatever functionality they
need, whether it's wrapping a
library, right?
I've seen people do things like
wrap the Google Maps API.
Make tags out of G Maps.
Which is really cool.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: It's a
really useful way to
repackage that stuff.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Just
things like that.
We're really excited about
the possibilities of
where this takes you.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So the last one
last is the one actually
I'm most excited about.
And that's polymer UI elements,
which I said in an
email, I think, last week.
The name is a mouthful.
I'm sure we'll change
it at some point.
But the idea of this is
actually, this is the one
that's really starting
to come together.
It's really early stages.
We talked a little bit about
I/O and Linus Upson talked
about it in the keynote,
as well.
We want to build a comprehensive
set of
opinionated UI elements.
So these are just web components
that can be used
with other web components
and their arrival.
In fact, you see here
other green boxes.
Those represent other
frameworks, other sorts of
components.
But we want to help people so
that when you start off you
don't have to go start from
scratch to put a web app.
You just say, I want this kind
of thing, this kind of thing.
Here's my app.
We can automatically do
that app try style on
the left for you.
That kind of thing.
So this is the area I'm most
excited about because we've
got a bunch of people who are
excited to help take this
Google design skill that's been
growing for all kinds of
new apps, like the Maps apps
on the Android and iOS, and
really bring that to a
library and let other
developers use it too.
ERIC BIDELMAN: And bring that
sort of thing to the web.
Where it's really easy to
drop that in your app.
You don't have to, like
Alex said, reinvent
the wheel every time.
And you can pick and choose
different elements from
different UI vendors.
And if they're all using this
web components, these
standards-based APIs under the
hood, it's very easy, as a
developer, to then interopt
with those between the
different elements.
So I think that's the exhaustive
explanation of this
diagram here.
But really, again, our
philosophy is to really
embrace HTML.
Love it.
Declarative first.
Everything's a custom element.
And if you're checking out
Polymer for the first time or
if you've seen it before, it
takes a while to wrap your
head around that.
But it really is making custom
elements in HTML.
Telling HTML about new things
and building those.
I think we sort of
alluded to it.
But another thing that we're
very interested in is evolving
with the web platform.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Right.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So I think
I saw a question.
And feel free to ask any
questions on our Google
Moderator page that we
have set up for you.
But it's really about evolving
with the web platforms.
So staying on the cutting edge
as these standards evolve.
Staying up to date.
And so we actually made an
explicit goal to try to only
support the [INAUDIBLE]
of each browser.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: That's
very deliberate.
Was it you that said,
someone said.
A wise man once said, maybe
Eric, said if all you're doing
is watching in the rear view
mirror, you're going to run
into something.
You're going to crash.
And so we're trying to make
sure that this future that
we're all going to get to,
soon, in the near future.
That when we get there we don't
go, oh, it's pretty much
like the past.
We want to get, we think this
is actually a much bigger, a
revolution where
we're going to.
I really want to emphasize, too,
the Polymer team, we work
with Blink guys.
We're active on all the
standards lists.
Our goal as a team is if the
standard that's developing,
that's evolving, we don't think
it's the right thing
based on our experience and
the feedback we're getting
from polymer-dev and other
people who are using this,
then we should help make those
arguments in the standards
bodies to change that.
This is a feedback thing.
It's not like, oh, we do what
the standards body says, no,
we're actually involved
in this.
MATT MCNULTY: That's something
we've done a lot in the last
year or so.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Absolutely.
And a lot of it comes, too,
from feedback we get in
polymer-dev.
Some people saying, well,
this feels weird to me.
It's like, well, the reason
that's in the standard is for
this reason.
They go, I really don't think
that makes a lot of sense.
And we can take that feedback
back and point to that and
say, hey, developers don't
understand this.
ERIC BIDELMAN: It turns out
there's a lot of really smart
developers out there.
They all don't work at Google.
They all work at these
big companies.
And we absolutely value
their expertise when
building and stuff.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I've been
thrilled with the amount of
stuff we've gotten
in polymer-dev.
Really great questions
and feedback.
And smart people coming up with
new ways of using this
stuff and asking really
hard questions.
It's really good.
ERIC BIDELMAN: And to this
next point here, but
boilerplate code.
This is something that no
developer likes is to write a
lot of boilerplate over
and over again.
And it turns out just with these
platform APIs there is a
lot of code that you have to
write over and over again.
And that's something Polymer
is sort of addressing and
that's part of our opinion
is to minimize that.
Some of the tedious app things
that you're going to have to
do when creating a
custom element.
And then we've alluded to it, as
well, salt to taste is the
terminology we used
on the team a lot.
And that's really that you
could pick and choose the
different layers
of that stack.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: This is
really important.
And I said this in the email
again last week.
But the primary goal of this
project, we're really excited
about Web Components.
We've been excited about
them for years.
I remember, two, three, years
ago I talked with Alex Russell
at I/O about Web Components
and how excited we were.
The goal, for us, is to help
kick off and bootstrap what we
ultimately hope to be a thriving
ecosystem built
around Web Components.
And that's not specifically
about Polymer.
Polymer is something that's
trying to lead the way here.
But we want this to be a
thriving [INAUDIBLE] with
other people too.
And that's what we have a clear
layering of the stack.
And we've talked to other
people who are using
individual polyfills or a bunch
of them to do their own
frameworks.
And that is awesome.
That is great.
That's exactly why we're
doing it this way.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So with that, do
you want to switch to demos
and actually show a little bit
what we're talking about here?
MATT MCNULTY: Sure.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Inspire
us, sir.
MATT MCNULTY: All right.
So we have a screen here
is just a text editor.
And it contains a blank polymer
elements definition.
So this is the declarative
API.
There's an imperative
API as well.
So this one we're just creating
an element called
my-element.
And we can put tags inside of
other tags so we can start out
just putting in g-ratings,
which is
another one we created.
So if we do that, I
can preview this.
And you'll see that our little
rating stars pops up.
And you can play with it.
Cool.
It's a Web Component.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So just to
clarify, you're creating a new
element and you're using
somebody else's element that
they've already created.
Another custom element within
a custom element themself.
MATT MCNULTY: Yeah.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: That's cool.
MATT MCNULTY: So if you inspect
this in the web
inspector, you'll see that it's
hidden inside this grayed
out document fragment in
the developer tools.
What that means is it's
in the Shadow DOM.
So unless you have this little
check box showing Shadow DOM,
you won't see it.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: That's one
of the key notions of
encapsulation.
That's core to Shadow DOM.
MATT MCNULTY: So if you come
back here, one of the other
things we decided to do, it's
a little boring to just do
this with text.
So we built a little
GUI builder.
And this is just for demos.
You can't actually
save anything.
It's really just meant as
a playground to drag out
elements and see what's
exposed and make other
elements out of them, and
that kind of thing.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: It's a great
place to play around with
these things, get
a sense of them.
But one thing to note, and
you'll see it throughout this,
is that inspector, the panel on
the right, is just one to
one correspondence
with the markup.
It just saves you a little
bit typing, basically.
MATT MCNULTY: Yeah so the tool
has a canvas in the middle.
You can see this little
graph paper.
It's got a palette down the
left-hand side and has this
property inspector down
the right-hand side.
And the property inspector, as
Alex said, is just exposing
the properties of the
polymer element that
you're dealing with.
So you can see we have a whole
lot of things down here down
the left-hand side.
I'm going to play with
a couple of them.
I can bring out a menu.
I can bring out a toolbar.
And you can see, you can
place these things and
play around with them.
And it's actually, this isn't
doing anything special.
All it's doing is creating these
custom elements for you.
It's not generating any code
or doing anything special
behind the scenes.
This is the actual code that
runs when you preview this.
I can bring out tabs.
You see these things
are interactive.
You can play with them.
So one of the cool things we
mentioned, one of the little
red boxes in that diagram
was called MDV.
And that's short for
Model Driven Views.
And what that does is
really interesting.
It brings data binding
to the platform.
So in this case, in our little
polymer constructor here, I
can say, just make
up a variable.
So let's try and tie the
menu to the tabs.
So I created a variable
and I gave it a
default value of zero.
So now if I come up here into
the actual text, there we go.
That should be easier
for everyone to see.
If I come up here to
the actual toolbar,
sorry, not the toolbar.
The menu, the tab.s this says
selected equals one.
Instead I can replace
that with this
double mustache syntax.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Which is
familiar from lots of other
data binding earmarks as well.
MATT MCNULTY: And use the same
variable that I used down
there before.
And I come back into the
viewable side we can actually
do that in the tool itself.
So if I come into the
tabs, you could see
it's selected as well.
And if I come to the menu and
I bind it to the same thing,
now they're actually
bound together.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So you bound one
of those just directly in
code and one of them
using a tool.
Which, of course, was just doing
exactly the same thing.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Essentially
you added a
property to your element.
You define an element
in Mark Up.
You created whatever properties
and APIs on that,
as public methods
and properties.
And then you've data bound two
elements together using MDB.
Pretty powerful stuff.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Not even
a line a code, really.
I mean just--
MATT MCNULTY: Yeah.
We can take this entire thing.
And we can publish it
onto the palette.
And this is just temporary.
If you refresh it goes away.
And then the whole thing comes
out and you can see that
selected property that I added
just shows up here in the
property inspector.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So it's
being exposed out now.
MATT MCNULTY: And if you change
it you can see both of
the widgets change.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: One of the
things that you see in this
world where everything is an
element is you're just using
these building blocks to build
up larger and larger elements.
And then before you know it,
you've got actually whole
applications.
MATT MCNULTY: Yeah, you can do
interesting things with this.
We've got a YouTube widget.
Our YouTube widget has got an
I'm feeling lucky property.
Which is reasonably risky.
It's a voice-activated
YouTube widget.
It returns the very first thing
that it searches for,
which is what makes
it kind of risky.
For demos you can put a
speech input up there.
And we can actually bind the
two things together.
So if I go--
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So that's just
a regular Joe input with a
little speech attribute on it.
MATT MCNULTY: Yeah, this is
the default Chrome HTML5
speech input.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So native HTML
talking to custom elements
HTML, if you will.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Because
effectively a lot of the time,
actually, use elements,
they feel just
like any other elements.
Ones that are baked into the
platform with the inputs.
MATT MCNULTY: So if I go into
the little binding thing here
and I say, input.value is equal
to this I'm feeling
lucky property, and if you can
even look it up in the code.
And you'll see this
is dollars, I
didn't put that value.
It's still the same thing I
was showing you before.
Now if I come in here,
grumpy cat.
In a second.
Aha, there we go.
It shows it.
So you can see how you can
combine these things together.
And if you imagine you can
actually combine it into a
really large application.
Like this sandbox itself is
actually all built in polymer.
So one of the ways we can prove
that, we have it on the
palette here.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I don't
believe you, man.
Show us.
MATT MCNULTY: Exactly.
I'm lying.
We actually have the
whole sandbox
app here on the pallet.
So you can drag it
off as a widget.
And then drag it off
inside of itself.
ERIC BIDELMAN: The whole app
is an element, it's a tag.
It's an HTML tag.
And because of encapsulation,
right?
Because of Shadown DOM, because
of custom elements you
can then do things like this.
Which would actually be
crazy hard to do.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Yeah, it would
require a lot of work to do if
you're doing it by hand.
But here you sort of get
it for free, almost.
MATT MCNULTY: And encapsulation
ensures that
none of the semantics
leak at all.
So you can actually get things
inside of things.
And you can combine different
frameworks together.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's
really awesome.
Very cool.
Any other demos?
MATT MCNULTY: No, that's it.
ERIC BIDELMAN: With that.
That's great.
We learned a little
bit about Polymer.
Let's switch to do some Q&A and
to address some burning
issues here.
So first question,
what is your end
goal in building Polymer?
What's it's purpose?
Where does it fit in the
ecosystem of content
management systems, frameworks,
and libraries.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I will
take that one.
So I think I already, actually,
kind of answered
this going through it.
But our primary goal, I said
this in an email in
polymer-dev I think last
Friday or something.
Our primary goal in Polymer
is to bootstrap a thriving
ecosystem around
Web Components.
We think Web Components are
an amazing new technology,
emerging technology on
the web platform.
And we want to make sure that
the community, the ecosystem,
can use them productively and
really get started thinking
about these in the right way.
That's our primary goal.
We also, of course, as a
secondary goal to that, is to
have instead of amazing
[INAUDIBLE]
UI widgets.
So these are just web components
that can be used
like any other set.
And, of course, Polymer is
designed to be layered.
So you can take what you want
and don't take the parts you
don't want.
So if you want to use
a different sort of
widgets, it's A-OK.
ERIC BIDELMAN: I think
especially important to show,
with all these new standards
coming out, right?
Under on the web components
umbrella, MDV, Shadow DOM, all
this new stuff.
It's important to show people
how to use this in an
interesting way.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: And to discover
how to use it too.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Discover
how to use it.
I think that's really what
Polymer is trying do with the
whole layer.
The UI elements, the regular
elements, and down to the core
foundational layer.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: And there's
still great questions going on
in polymer-dev about, well
why'd you do it this way?
Is this really the right way?
We don't know.
We need to discover this as a
community and figure this out.
MATT MCNULTY: This is still very
much a work in progress.
It's changing constantly.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: And because
this is such an
exciting and new area.
The team that's been working on
this has worked on, what,
like five or six different
frameworks before.
And this is not new.
Working on frameworks is not
new, but working with web
components just is a
total mind shift.
MATT MCNULTY: And embracing
the platform again.
It's kind of old school.
You're going back to using
DOM again, right?
Everyone always asks us like,
well, how do you actually make
these things happen?
It's like DOM is
the framework.
That's all you have.
Outside of an element, you're
just using DOM.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So the second
part of this question then is
how does it fit within the
ecosystem of content
management systems,
frameworks, and other libraries.
So the existing stuff
really allows you to
be productive today.
And Polymer, again, we support
the modern browsers--
ERIC BIDELMAN: Evergreen
browsers.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Evergreen
browsers is the way that we
describe it.
A lot of things today that are
deployed that people are using
very successfully are targeted
to the web of today.
And we are trying
to help build a
better web of tomorrow.
And so it's fundamentally a
different kind of a framework
because it's one of our goals is
to take this feedback back
into the standardization
process.
To not play fast and loose and
say, oh this doesn't work.
We'll just do this
other thing.
No, no, no, let's fix
that thing, right?
So that everyone else
can benefit from it.
ERIC BIDELMAN: And like we
said before, there's been
numerous framework authors that
have come on our mailings
and said they're fully
supportive of where things are
headed with the platform
stuff, Shadow DOM, Web
Components, custom elements.
They can embrace some of these
lower level technologies and
then use that within their
own framework.
So I think it fits
in really well.
If you think of web development
as a holistic
approach with all this stuff
that's happening.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: I think there's
definitely, the use of
the polymer-dev mailing list
has become sort of the de
facto place where people talk
about web components concepts.
So Polymer is bigger than
just Polymer, per se.
It's Web Components that we're
talking about a lot here.
MATT MCNULTY: This is one of the
first things that actually
puts all of these things
together and shows you how to
build and what you can do.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Cool.
Is Polymer already being used
in some Google projects?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So Polymer
is in pre alpha.
Which means that if you aren't
OK with it breaking without
warning, it's not ready
for you yet.
MATT MCNULTY: If there was a
Greek letter that was before A
we would be calling it that.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: And then
the thing is, it's
actually pretty solid.
You should definitely
play around with it.
And if you're using it for
production stuff, let us know.
Let us know what breaks,
what doesn't work.
Where it's not working
for you.
But at this point it's
definitely too early for major
Google projects to
be using this.
But I will say, I've been
interested to see all the
excitement coming from
teams internally too.
So we're seeing a lot of the
excitement externally.
People are interested in this
stuff and following along.
ERIC BIDELMAN: I was just going
to point out that when
we first talked about I/O, one
of the Google engineers,
actually, was building a
performance dash for Chrome.
And ended up using Polymer.
Wanted to get nitty gritty
with custom elements.
And so she ended up building
a dashboard in Polymer.
And using custom elements,
eliminating a lot of
boilerplate code, fixing bugs
she always had issues with.
It's really cool stuff.
And I think we've seen a lot
of internal interest from
different teams and engineers at
Google really excited about
where this web platform
stuff is going.
MATT MCNULTY: Yeah, she did it
actually without any help.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Very cool.
MATT MCNULTY: Where is
the file for this?
A couple week later it was like,
hey, here's the thing.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Annie's also
an amazing engineer, too.
But we're seeing, already,
interest in smaller projects
like this are using it.
And I think, over time,
naturally, as smaller projects
had success, that means it
allows larger products to take
it seriously and really use
it for real things.
And it works up from there.
So not yet.
But that's because it's very,
very, very early days.
And we wouldn't encourage them
to use it at this point.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Cool.
What browsers does Polymer
support in its polyfills?
Are there any plans
to support all the
versions of this browser?
I actually ask this because
this comes up a lot.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: See I
recognize that name.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Weird.
And so I just want to touch
up on the point.
We're trying to support the
latest and greatest of every
bottom browser.
And that includes the Evergreen
browsers, the latest
version of IE, the latest
version of Chrome.
And it's really because we want
to evolve this as the web
platform evolves, as well.
You can't do that you if you are
looking back in the rear
view mirror as Alex
said before.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So there's
definitely, this isn't like a
hard line stance of older
browsers are terrible.
We need to make sure that we're
focusing on the future.
So if it's possible in some
cases, every so often, oh, it
just basically works in older
versions of IE or whatever, in
some cases.
And it's fine.
ERIC BIDELMAN: And sometimes,
too, it's
an engineering problem.
Sometimes you just can't
polyfill Shadow DOM and the
beast that it is browsers like
older versions of IE.
It's impossible.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Shadow DOM
polyfill is already an amazing
work of engineering from Erik
Arvidsson, who's an amazing
engineer as well.
MATT MCNULTY: And we're saying
too that you can't actually
polyfill everything.
So there are certain features,
there are certain aspects of
things that aren't there yet.
ERIC BIDELMAN: That's
a really good point.
MATT MCNULTY: We try
and do our best to
highlight what those are.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Right.
So we have, some are polyfills
and some are, I would call
more of a shim, right?
It tries to mimic as much
as possible the need of
functionality.
Things like CSS scoping
is very hard to do.
Is there a trade off when
using a Polymer element?
We gain the benefits of the
Polymer framework, but with
the added dependency.
Alternatively you could build
a custom element, just a raw
straight custom element
in CSS JavaScript.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So one thing I
want to clarify really quickly
is, again we're using these
standards and we're feeding
back into them.
And they're evolving as we
speak in response to some
other things that we and others
are saying in these
standards list.
And so custom elements,
actually, as of right now, I
believe it doesn't have the
eclarative syntax that we were
using in early versions of
Polymer is temporarily on hold
while they figure out the
imperative bits and get that
really lined up and
solidified.
And so we didn't want to use
these semantics that may
change in the future.
And so Polymer element allows
us to experiment and provide
something that was like,
we think this is a good
way of doing it.
And that will feedback into the
standardization process.
And we'll see ultimately,
hopefully, you just use
roughly element.
MATT MCNULTY: So obviously we're
biased, I think Polymer
is totally worth it.
But on thing to point out is
it's a very, very thin layer.
Actually it's the thinnest layer
we can possibly make it.
And the goal is as these
standards evolve and as more
of what we consider best
practices turn into the
platform, it gets even
thinner over time.
Dom is the framework, that means
we don't have to create
one in JavaScript.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So, again,
we've talked about this
multiple times throughout this,
but our goal is when we
see something in the emerging
standards that, we're going to
work around that.
No, no, no.
We go back and we bring this
feedback back to the standards
guys and work collaboratively
to solve that.
This is just an example of you
watching it in motion.
MATT MCNULTY: And there are some
people working with the
polyfills directly that are on
the mailing list as well.
And a lot of times they find
themselves looking at the
Polymer file just
for a reference.
ERIC BIDELMAN: And part of the
change, actually, I will say
with the Polymer element, is
that we took some feedback,
actually, from developers
on the mailing list.
They want to do things
like render CSP,
Context Security Policy.
And they wanted to separate
their script from the actual
element declarative
definition.
And so that is part of the
Polymer element change as well
is to bootstrap that a little
easier now before the native
stuff is ready.
Cool.
Where are we guys?
Why must custom element
names have a dash?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So this
is a spec requirement.
And the reason that it's in
there, and I hope I don't
butcher this.
But the reason it's in there
is because when you're
developing new specs you want
to make sure that you don't
accidentally break
existing content.
So you don't want to stomp on
people's feet what they've
already done.
And so we're giving people
a very powerful new
functionality.
And say we, the web component
standards.
A very powerful functionality.
So say everyone starts going off
and creating tags one and
then later we want to formally
standardize that.
We ship it with slightly
different semantics.
Well now we've just
broken content.
And so the idea of having a
dash is that basically new
things that are built into the
platform won't have a dash.
And so we guarantee that the
user LAN components won't ever
conflict with [INAUDIBLE].
MATT MCNULTY: It's a really good
example of the feedback
to the spec process.
Because originally about a year
ago you had to have an x
dash every single tag.
And the first time we started
actually using that we have
all of these tags and every
single one of them had an x
tag in them.
It was like, OK, this
is not ideal.
If there's something we can do
to actually make that easier,
that would be great.
So we switched to just has a
dash as the minimum we could
come up with.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Why do you use
the ng-app tag at Google I/O.
Something to do with
AngularJS?
MATT MCNULTY: I don't
believe we did.
ERIC BIDELMAN: There was a video
but it had the g dash
app, right?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Oh yes.
That's the confusing.
So that video that we showed is
kind of like our vision of
where we want to go.
MATT MCNULTY: Halo video.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: And so that
actually is a g dash app.
And the idea there was just
showing off components in the
way how Web Components work to
set a future picture of how it
could work in the future
when you build apps.
So actually, gs app
is a real thing.
It's not ngApp.
It's not really to the
angular concept.
It's just we needed a name
to put in that video.
ERIC BIDELMAN: It
is confusing.
Like Linus was up on stage.
There was an awesome
video, right?
It was very inspirational
and everything.
But people like think
Google is building
new elements in HTML.
No.
It was to show the custom
elements stuff.
And we just happened to have the
dash as the first part of
that phrase.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: That's funny, I
haven't heard that confusion
before, but I can see why.
That makes total sense.
ERIC BIDELMAN: How does Polymer
work with AngularJS
That's interesting.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: That is
an interesting one.
So first of all, Angular
is amazing framework.
What's so cool about what
Angular has done is they've
helped people think
declaratively.
Lots of other framers
haven't done that.
So that's really cool.
Polymer and web components, the
idea is that when you get
a reference to this component,
it's just a component.
It emits events.
It takes attributes.
It has imperative
methods on it.
And so when you're using these
things, your other framework
shouldn't have to
know about them.
They're just elements, right?
They're just like
any other ones.
It's when you want to use some
of the extra sugaring features
or extra capabilities built into
Polymer and Angular that
it doesn't really work perfectly
right now, I think.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Yeah, so you can
absolutely today build an
app that uses parts
of Angular.
One thing that's nice about
Angular, you can pick and
choose in Angular as well.
Part of your app
can be Angular.
The whole thing can
be Angular.
And it's sort of the same
with Polymer as well.
You can make, like Matt
just showed, right?
You can make an entire
sandbox that's a tag.
That's a Polymer app.
And with inside of it, there's
other Polymer elements.
So by itself, these
two frameworks can
work absolutely together.
You can create a component
here in Angular.
Component here in Polymer.
Custom elements.
And they work really
well together.
I think one thing I've seen is
people trying to use like a
framework inside of Polymer and
that's where it starts to
get challenging.
And that's really due to the
complications of Shadow DOM
Because a lot these frameworks,
jQuery, et cetera.
And APIs, actually service
APIs, expect to be in the
global name space.
They expect to have a window
object, for instance.
And so now we're switching this
paradigm of encapsulation
where there's Shadow DOM
in other things.
And you're not in that
same global context.
So you have to compartmentalize
functionality.
MATT MCNULTY: We like thinking
about there's a barrier at the
inside of an element versus the
outside of the element.
And if you have two different
things on the inside of the
element, that's going
to be a problem.
But if you have a different
thing on the outside of the
element than inside the
element, you're fine.
ERIC BIDELMAN: It's like who
understands the mustache
syntax when you're inside
of a [INAUDIBLE].
Polymer or Angular, it's hard.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So outside
doesn't matter who you're
using it with.
It's inside where you pick
one to work with.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Right.
Cool.
Did I lose my place again?
Are there any Polymer Web
Components build tools for
concatenating and minifying
Web Components?
I'll just take a stab at
this real quickly.
I think it's very early days
for tooling for Web
Components.
I'm particularly excited about
where things can go for this
sort of thing.
A lot of people have asked us
really great questions on our
mailing lists and
RFC channels.
It's going to be important, when
you have a slew of these
custom elements that you're
building, you want to then
have your normal bill process.
You went to concatenate
things.
You want to [INAUDIBLE]
JavaScript, combine everything,
and have those
good best practices.
Again, really early, we've
already started experimenting
with some of this becomes it's
come up enough that we should
obviously start thinking
about it now.
So Daniel on the team has
actually written a little node
tool that can sort of compress
and concatenate all your
elements into one.
MATT MCNULTY: It's called
Vulcanizer.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Vulcaniler.
Pretty gnarly name.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: But I think that
one thing to emphasize as
well is HTML imports allows you
to package up components
as an HTML file.
We don't yet know what the best
practices are to use that.
And so I think it's
really early.
We're still trying to explore
what that looks like.
We're talking to various
networking experts in the
specification process to really
figure out what are the
best practices.
And so we don't yet know.
It will probably have some
sort of concatenation and
minifying, but we don't exactly
know what it's going
to look like.
Because it's early.
ERIC BIDELMAN: It is early.
Cool.
Will you be aiming and making
the transition from Polymer to
real web components when
they are ready?
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Switch
back to the diagram.
This is a common
misconception.
So Polymer, actually, when we
say Polymer we mean a bunch of
different things.
And in this diagram, the brown
on the left shows what Polymer
means when we talk about it.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Alex is
right over here.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: Thank you thank
you for pointing to that
with your pointing device.
ERIC BIDELMAN: I don't know how
well the brown shows up on
the screen.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: So
the red later,
ultimately, is just the standards.
It's just polyfills.
And when those are implemented
natively across all the
different browsers,
it just goes away.
These are Web Components.
And so the layer of the yellow
and the green, those are sort
of sugar an opinion that
Polymer adds on.
But they are web components.
These are not some special,
crazy other world.
And so this might be referring
to the Polymer
element versus element.
And, again, we answer that
earlier a few minutes ago.
MATT MCNULTY: It could also
be the transition
to Native as well.
So right now in Chrome Canary,
Polymer is using native
Shadown DOM optionally.
And very soon, hopefully, we'll
have some of the other
pieces in Native as well.
So as those things transition,
you'll see different browsers
move to Native as we go along.
And, again, Polymer is going
to try and be that
thin layer on top.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So the
answer is yes.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: We're
already there.
ERIC BIDELMAN: So I think
we're out of questions.
We really appreciate
you guys tuning in.
And definitely we would like
to have more of these.
If you're interested in checking
out Polymer, the URL
for documentation in the site
is polymer-project.org.
So you can download Polymer
there and all the goodness
that we talked about today.
And learn some of
the features.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: One thing I will
say too, if you have any
ideas for things you want
to hear talk about.
You want to talk to Dimitri
about Web Components specs.
You want to talk to
Dominic about
implementing these in Blink.
You want to talk to Scott
about some of the
architecture decisions.
Or Steve about some of the
specifics of how this whole.
Let us know.
We're looking for ideas
of other things
that we talk about.
[INAUDIBLE]
polymer-dev or whatever
you want to do.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Totally.
Polymer-dev at Google Groups is
our mailing list if you're
interested in talking with us.
ALEX KOMOROSKE: A lot
of really good
conversation there.
ERIC BIDELMAN: Good stuff.
Cool.
We're signing off online.
We really appreciate
you guys's time.
Thanks for joining us.